baby
hi this turnout oh my god
i know i don't know i guess they came to
see someone else
no the words just getting out that's all
yeah i
i just i've been loving it so much i
don't want it to change it won't
you have me i won't let ya well i'm not
worried about me i'm worried about
it and the people not hearing the words
you don't need that
survivor is that perfume yeah do you
like it
uh do i have to uh oh no i like your
smell
i miss it how's it work i don't want to
talk about it
i don't want to talk about it unless
it's good good rule
let's go hi trek philly cheese what are
you cramming
you don't want to know no i don't
fortunately for you i already do rule of
adult life never talk about work unless
it's good
come here
you okay are you gonna puke
hey hey
so do you know what happened for the
first
time in this sleeping bag hmm i have no
idea well months ago
12 12 months
look at us keeping warm for an entire
year
i'm not a loser all right all right i'm
trying things right
by the time i'm your age you're old as
[ __ ]
i'm gonna be the ceo of a bank you know
i'm gonna be making like 120 000 or more
in like two years what are you doing
with your life no my mom would kick your
mom's [ __ ] ass
my mom is dead
do you wanna hug or something all right
sure
all right yeah not too close all right
we're very warm all right yeah that's
good
yeah that's good that's good that's good
i get that i used emoticons give me my
phone
okay we have the same dad yeah we're
brothers please give me my phone and
even though
we're not brothers i didn't teach you
how to live lesson
no no no wait what are you doing putting
it in what
no no no no no i've just been here
longer if it makes you feel any better
every single person outside in all of
those buildings every light and every
window contains someone going through
this exact thing
[Applause]
all uh-huh what's going on
tyler morrow how we doing welcome to the
program thanks for having me i'm i'm
happy to be here
the second time's our time yeah i know
yeah we uh we were fixing some of our
electrical problems at the house on the
first stream so we had to power
everything off
but we got to go out to the back and
have some great
conversations on medicine i think you
could host some of these out there it
was so serene
his backyard he's doing it yeah and the
little he's got this little fountain
next to the table it's beautiful like
that
very zen serene yeah super super zen
yeah and
yeah we were crushing it on those convos
it's just there's a lot of
the equipment to bring out there
yeah and to move it back and forth but
for example
a lot of oprah's super soul
sunday's videos are
outdoors at her massive venue
backyard yeah yeah yeah and so that's a
pretty
good aspiration is to take the convo out
into as nice it is is
being in a living room with a fireside
chat
side chat style man to be out there with
those birds chirping
oh yeah in that sense i'm telling you
that fountain makes it makes
uh it's game changing a whole bunch it
was helping me it was helping me keep up
he's hard to keep up with people so yeah
yeah so
kyle shadow introduced us yeah super
great kyle yeah he's the hell yeah
yeah he's a genius and you guys have
been collaborating together on
some projects and also you one of those
pieces of footage was on evan bliss's
rooftop which was funny
yes so it's funny you've had kyle and
zeb and evan on and actually i've i've
introduced all of them to
to each other funny enough so i brought
kyle to zeb and then they moved in
together i've known evan
for a long time uh since right after he
moved here
and i introduced him to kyle and him to
zeb
a while back so so whoa i got jealous i
was like when's when's my turn
yeah that's so great so you are the
connecting note amongst
yeah i guess and also uh
yeah i'm the i'm the through line that's
great yeah
there's great people very lucky to have
them hell yeah on the super connecting
yeah exactly so
tyler has 10 plus
films where he's had a principal role in
and as we got to see in that
reel a moment ago we're going to unpack
acting filmmaking tyler kind of has this
ability to be
like a jedi and navigate all of the
different
tones and all of the different different
presences that are being asked by the
writers for him to be able to channel
and that is a very good skill set it's
kind of like
joseph and the code of many colors from
the biblical stories yeah yeah
yeah stuff like that and in that first
session what we were talking about
before we had to cut it short
was that tyler made this comparison
where he said that each one of these
productions is like its universe
yeah and like here we have our you know
math and physics and our story that is
being told here our spirituality all
this type of stuff
and each one of these productions has
their own tone
and their own essence that they want the
actors and the actresses to be able to
portray yeah i think the best way to
approach it as an actor is like a
behavioral law of physics right
so the in a certain project that might
be darker in tone
in in that in that world people aren't
going to be light-hearted and people
aren't gonna aren't gonna
be low stakes with everything
everything's gonna be heightened higher
stakes
uh you know and and the situation's
gonna match and then usually what
happens in comedy is that there's an
asymmetry so you have someone that has
these heightened heightened stakes over
something as innocuous as a cell phone
or or the world around them is just
blowing up it's insane and they're kind
of just the normal guy
those are kind of the two comedies that
you typically see
um are ordinary people in extraordinary
worlds or
ordinary worlds with extraordinary
people
wow okay that's such a cool way to put
it so like the drama
is like the heightened sense in an
ordinary world of like this
scenario that might which we'll portray
in the next video yeah the next one's
more of the drama
side of my body of work and then
the the
the extraordinary sort of
asymmetry that occurs where somebody is
very
kind of relaxed while somebody else is
super heightened
about that's comedy yeah well and you
can you can
um with the one on bliss's rooftop it's
the one
it's a little i shot it on my t3i i
think
no anyway it's the it's the one where
i'm wearing the tie
for the for the audience that one you
kind of have that
they're both kind of heightened
characters but i would say my character
is more than every man in the situation
and the other guy's kind of the like
bigger explosive
lunatic and ideally that's kind of where
the comedy
is created you know as is the
juxtaposition of these two and they have
to deal with each other
like um jason bateman is like he's
always the everyman guy like in curb
your enthusiasm he's the normal person
trying to
reign in the crazy world around him yeah
yeah yeah
it's exciting for me to unpack
the knowledge that you now
have from eight years now in the
acting and filmmaking here in los
angeles so was it born and raised in
colorado and pueblo
yeah yeah southeast colorado
i think people when they hear colorado
they think aspen
think kansas it looks a lot more like
kansas
small town and um
i guess if we're getting into it the the
first thing
that hit me i can remember where i was
like i want to do that funny enough was
the rugrats movie
there's this scene with the brothers and
the rain
and the older brother has this jealousy
because it's the new baby and all that
like embarrassing myself it's great i
love this so i start
crying dude i'm like this little kid i
start crying and i get addicted to that
to crying to the rugrats movie and i
think that was the
first like thing where it's like oh
that's what i want to do whatever this
is doing to me that's that's what i want
to do
oh for other people right or just in
general just in general
yeah and i think that's why i prefer
acting
um to the other ones is because only
only one person gets to actually like
live in it you know i mean the writer
does and they get to create a
the actor is the one that gets to dress
up like a pirate and run around and just
be a lunatic you know
so that's i think that's the biggest
appeal for me you know is getting to
live
just to play pretend for a living yeah
yeah yeah which is what this is on like
a metaphysical level as well yeah
this in many ways is as shakespeare said
actress and actresses
that are all taking their role on the
right all the worlds of stage all the
world's a stage and then
similarly now it's just like as a buff
so below
now you do it as well yeah on top of
that
yeah i must be you know i think that
uh my my going theory is that like life
is kind of like a video game
in essence like if you have a that if
if there's you know if you believe in
the immortal soul the mortal soul gets
bored
of being immortal and all-knowing and
creates
life and existence to kind of occupy
itself for
a set amount of time and so i must be
like really addicted to it because i
chose that game and then i love games
and then i play pretend
uh you know as a living yeah so yeah and
it's it's the best i mean
yeah it's yeah and also just
uh the journey that you go on pursuing
it is
insane it's it's hard and it's it's
rewarding so that that part's
the best too yeah yep
yeah the we were talking about this
outside also lila in sanskrit the divine
play
and that is in very many ways what this
this non-dual not two enigma
mystery is up to is these divine plays
that are unfolding and that we
get the
the playful the more that we carry a
child like
play and innocence and peace
i'm feeling the shivers man yeah the
more we keep and
that as our essence the more in a sense
we are with the if you will the the
spirit of the formless of that
unmanifested of that source or that god
and that as these expressions
of that we get to
actualize all these different roles
and and that's the thing you know they
don't they they don't call it a play for
no reason
you're so it's supposed to be really fun
you know and
that sense of that sense of play is
something that's
really important to me and i try to
act on all the time you know like if you
go out to nature especially you can feel
it if you laugh
if you allow your imagination to kind of
take control
and that's something that the the
practice of acting
is really good as it teaches you to let
your imagination do it
you know i think the older we get the
more we're supposed to push down these
these wild imaginations and the more
we're supposed to live in the real world
and put on the tie and you know get the
house and get the kids and all that and
all that stuff's great and it has its
own rewards but
that sense of play is something that is
just so important to me
and i think that's a a lesson that
everyone
could learn from that child-like
wonderment it's the
it's when you can you can feel it
a lot with nature in particular like
just play in the ocean
or dance like a fool or i love the
mountains
obviously i'm from colorado why wouldn't
i and i love like running around the
mountains and
telling myself these crazy stories in my
head i love
telling myself these stories oh there's
a guy who's got a gun he's after you you
know
so i turned that illness into a into a
skill into an instrument but i
that's something that just it drives me
it's just
my favorite thing to do is just to let
that run wild the imagination
yeah that's why
it's called imagineering at disney yeah
exactly this is it's so important that
the child like
explorative imagination is not
quelled by the economic
machinery that sort of indoctrinates
children into separation and into
ego and into pursuit
of money and yeah material objects yeah
exactly exactly and the more that we
sort of let the child's imagination
roar the more that they are able to
provide solutions to many of the
greatest challenges that we
face as a planet as well yeah and that's
something that
is really great about movies in
particular
if you think about it the the iphone was
on star trek in the 60s so because you
don't have to abide by any of this real
world bs
when you make something up you you can
actually end up solving problems that
haven't even come up yet you know
uh i you see a lot in films right now
people are
filmmakers writers screenwriters in
particular are
wrapping their head around the idea of
climate change this impending doom that
is very real
and some of these movies are coming up
the solutions who knows 10
20 30 years down the line they actually
might have to implement these solutions
that people are coming up with
and fictitious work you know it wouldn't
be the first time
yeah yeah
that's a really critical part of
filmmaking and writing
in general is to as you
create art it's actually most principled
in
art in general as the most umbrella term
we can say here
that whether you're writing a book or
music or film or whatever it is
that the more that your
expressing the truest essence of
what you're here to express
at the same time as communicating
something of
wisdom of value of
relevancy of solutions
of insight
to maximize well-being or prosperity or
abundance
for society that's kind of like the
sweet point
of art yeah on a on a societal level
i think art can also impact you on a
personal level
totally one for me was like good will
hunting in particular
um that's a that's a film where i think
anyone who watches it gets the sense
that you're not alone
you know in a really intimate way we're
really cut off we live in our own worlds
in fact even the family unit is kind of
disappearing as it becomes so you're
you're seeing people that are really
really isolated to themselves
so that's something that art does to me
that's really impactful is i'll see
something and i'll be so vulnerable and
so
true to life the more specific you get
the more broad it is everyone knows that
right with art
but the more the more that someone's
putting their heart and soul into it
that affects you that shows you you're
not alone
and that's that's in a sense an act of
unity
which i think we do need our square
footage gets bigger and our friends
groups get smaller every year
yeah and a massive measure of
happiness is how many close friends you
have at the end of your life
another sort of way to approach
um talking about this is sort of
unpacking for us the
essence of what it was like making the
move
out here so
you know the rugrats moving and getting
excited and yeah
yeah and then like
you know at 17 making the move out here
i was saying that i
moved to silicon valley when i was 19
myself
and it's important for people to
sort of hear about these like leaps of
faith that people take
and just to hear yours
and then sort of those early
formulations when you first landed here
about getting your first gig so walk us
through that
okay so i'll take it back just a little
um i see the rugrats movie i go i want
to do that
i started working with a local theater a
couple of them but one one in particular
a bunch of years there and i'm talking
to all these older people
all these adults you know in a tribal
sense
so i end up going to this art high
school in denver
the denver school of arts it's a great
school and
i'm i'm looking at myself from 17 and
i'm like i'm not gonna graduate until
i'm 19.
then you know even if i go to juilliard
which is like as great as it gets i get
out of there what like 24
so i'm hitting la with no credits
so and i didn't want to do that sorry
i'm like
way ahead of myself so i called my mom
and i was like if i got accepted into a
college would you be okay with me moving
to la
and she was like of course because she
never thought that would happen
so i came out here i auditioned for a
couple schools first one that accepted
me i got my ged that weekend
threw everything in my car and drove out
here
and then went to that school for about a
year and then
we were on that interim period from year
to year so in that time
i went out and i got an agent i booked a
short film and then i booked there's
many leicas
uh and you're not supposed to be working
when you're at the school you're not
supposed to be auditioning so they call
me they're like are you
you know uh are you coming back for the
second year and i was like i really
can't have all these schedule conflicts
and then after that it was just like
this wild ride of auditions and
obviously working bartender stuff blah
blah blah and then not having to
because you got some ad and you think
that you're
when you when you get your first tv spot
you think that it's just going to happen
over and over and over again endlessly
so you just quit your job and you're
just like i got
15 grand it'll last me forever and then
you wake up broke one day so it's been
it's been a crazy journey in that way
but
the for me i was really lucky
to get that support right even with that
caveat
so they were really helpful with me to
that they helped me with the whole move
my parents
and um and the leap of faith
i didn't feel that as much i didn't feel
like it was a hard decision to make i
felt like it was the only decision to
make amen
it's the i didn't have any other option
in my head
yeah there's no plan b baby yeah exactly
only the plan a figure figure it out as
he go i guess
yeah um
would it be fair to say that
most of the
dynamics of especially
kind of los angeles are that style of
you know applying for the auditions
yourself to start
and then going to these different
casting
calls where you're
performing what is being asked of you in
a role
yeah and then yeah getting a green light
you're like yes you know whether it's an
ad or whatever it is and then getting
some sort of maybe chunk of change
but simultaneously having to work
another gig oh yeah to be able to get by
oh yeah and so this sort of process of
thinking that yeah it's just going to
keep rolling in
doors do open they do open but it's not
so like sudden that it's exponential no
immediately it takes a really while yeah
you do like
you know and i'm not the i've run into
if you work at a restaurant for 10
minutes here you'll
meet a thousand actors that all work
with you and it's
it happens to a lot of people you book
this one ad
it's five figure check you're like that
was a day work for five figures
i'm set and then it doesn't happen again
you know and the yeah so that was
something i did i was like no i can
ride this all the way i've got this
string of string of gigs
and that was a hard lesson to learn i
kind of wish i just kept
working and bought a house you know so
um uh yeah but it's it's not that
uncommon i think a lot of people
when they get that first big check they
think it's okay now it's happening i put
in the work and it the work just doesn't
end
so then is it also fair to say that
usually
after you get one of those first gigs
that then you are looking
for a manager and an agent oh
i would i mean does it take to get that
in motion like
approximately when does that happen you
should be trying to do it all the time
all the time so right as soon as you
right from the beginning yeah okay
if um you know if it
what you what you want to do uh is get
good headshots and they cost right now
about like 600
700 for about three good pictures but
it's worth the money
um you want to get a demo reel the
cheapest way to go about it is to book
student films and then as soon as you
have those two things
screw your resume screw it all you
should just be emailing tons of
agents you want you want to be
represented as soon as possible
yeah and and uh you know you usually
want to have the manager
and the agent and if the agent gets you
the big gig it's worth the 25
yeah you should just that should be a
massive priority
or at least it was for me and it worked
out well yeah yeah
yeah that's beautiful so head shots
and demo reel yeah what do you what do
you put in your demo reel if you
just whatever footage you have i mean um
do you like go out and like
do something and like have the student
capture that and then you go and do
something else and have the student
capture that and then just stitch all
these things if you're in la you've got
these great film schools
and part of their curriculum is to make
student films right to make films
as projects so submit for as many of
those as possible it's actually
great it's the safe place to practice
the audition process
especially so you don't make an ass of
yourself in front of like casting
directors
which i'm sure i did i feel like i kind
of
jumped the gun um but yeah submit for
everything that you can
as soon as you have any footage you
should be sending it to
agents i believe um as soon as you have
any footage
uh my first reel when i came out here i
did some stuff
with some kids from the colorado film
school was
horrible it was horrible but it got me
the rep and then the rep gets you
to work yep and in this case the rep
is the agent the agent yeah yeah yeah
someone that represents you
yeah rep representative yeah your agent
you know the person that's throwing you
at every wall seeing what's inside
exactly
or your manager like yeah yeah so
explain also the difference between the
agent and the manager
um it used to be it used to be a lot
bigger of a difference um a manager
they're gonna have a smaller client list
it's a different license believe it or
not they're all licensed
it's like regulated it's a different
license
a manager you should typically you
should typically expect like
more hands-on care and take care of you
a little bit more they're gonna
probably have a little more input on
your materials and stuff and
uh broadly speaking they're probably
gonna fight for you a little harder than
an agent is going to
an agent usually has like 100 clients
100 plus and manager typically has like
50 at the high end
so that's the main thing it's just more
attention and care and if you don't have
an agent and managers
one of their big jobs is to help you get
that agent that's like what they're kind
of expected to do
yeah and then the manager's taking like
10 and the asians taking 20 or something
yeah it's all negotiable um a manager
it's more typical for a manager to get
15 and an agent to get 10 percent
and then agent usually only gets a
commission on something they get you
and depending on your contract a manager
might get a percentage of everything you
do
yeah but that's all it's all negotiable
you know just like any
agent relationship and are they like
multiple year-long commitments
or what is it like i mean
so you have a bail usually so some of
them will make you sign a contract
just depends i'm not currently in
contract with either
we're just working together um
if they do make you sign a contract it's
like a year to two years okay
uh and but you have a 90 day bail period
if you don't get work within 90 days you
don't like the thing you can bail
yeah yeah you're not locked in unless
they get you work exactly
yeah yeah cool interesting and so then
what was it like first
you're putting yourself out there and
then the agent is putting you out there
afterward that's usually that was the
process yeah yeah beginning
and then sort of you should never stop
putting yourself
on either there there are opportunities
that are put out for actors
almost every day you should i think you
should chase those too you know
just to save yourself some time not
saying i always have
i used to just wait for the phone to
ring but now i chase it down
there are even facebook groups that have
leads and stuff you can just chase stuff
all day yeah one of the biggest
auditions i had last year
was a great part and then ultimately get
it but i found the dude on facebook
and like it was like yo can i audition
for this movie yeah he was like yeah
yeah
he was he was open to it yep so
yeah there's like this we'll probably
touch on this
throughout as well but the parable of
the prodigal son
is so profound here because in a sense
when we invest our time
in going on the outward exploration
that if we haven't done this
inner work if we haven't god
realized if we haven't recognized that
we
are that expressing itself eternally
and that this is just one manifestation
in form
of what that is that
what we do is we egoically go outward we
go outward
as a separate entity seeking something
that is missing
and we also seek conspicuous consumption
and fame and all these other things
versus if you really do the inner work
first
it's almost like an effortless action on
the way out so it's kind of like this
balance
between you almost know
at an intuitive level that's just coming
through you naturally
when to kind of
yin in a sense and
versus yang pursue oh i see
right and so for these acting gigs or
for this show
in many ways for the people to interview
and all this stuff
right now i'm in a very like yin state
with the show because i'm still kind of
hammering out some of the final touches
of non-duality and consciousness that
i'm sort of
putting into a lot of the visualizations
as we were talking right
back and so that's sort of acting as the
foundational frameworks is another
biblical story where
it's about the building you're and this
is very related to the parable of the
prodigal son where you're
you're building your house foundation
after you've went
all the way to rock versus building it
on sand
which is when the flood comes and then
wipes away the house but the one on rock
is steady and that's when you go inward
first
everything you do outward has nothing to
do with
seeking does nothing to do with seeking
only the ignorance seek what's already
there
but it remains for you to recognize it
but
what you're doing instead is you're
literally just acting as
a beautiful channel of
the natural expression that it is not
seeking greed not seeking fame yeah
definitely
yeah you know i think i think that
that might be one of the things that
separate people that stick around and
people that leave
is the is that if if uh
if getting an audition is enough to make
you happy for the day
because you can express yourself that
way you're probably in the right
business
you know or you're probably the right
type of person to be in the business
you know um i i've gone through
actually it might be something like
being happy is
what you are fundamentally right
and then whether you get auditions or
not
does not affect the internal peace and
happiness
yeah i'm still working on that but let
me tell you this
i'll tell you this happiness breeds
success success does not breed happiness
is is one way i've heard it like
happiness
happiness precedes success and i think
that one of the great lies we're told
by society is that happiness proceeds
success
and that's the similar with that parable
of the prodigal son is that
you really find that well of honey
that's under the rock first yeah and
then you go out effortlessly to express
yourself
it's funny i've people are seeking the
well of honey externally
i've had i bounce back and forth i'm
working on it um
i there have been periods in my life
where it's just stuff's coming in
and i couldn't be happier you know and
it is effortless then you know
when things yeah there's i've had that
where it's just felt effortless
and great things are happening left and
right and your greatest test is going to
be
that peace and bliss
and childlike innocence like we were
talking about
at your quote most worst times
yeah and so
it's not to see everything as one
homogeneous
blob but it's to
come from that place of childlike
innocence
peace bliss and play and exploration
divine play yeah and if it's a truly a
divine play
you would ask yourself something like
if i know my source truly
yeah why would i ever be miserable
well i don't know there's a lot there's
a here there's a big defense for misery
no there's a big defense for misery it's
it's a wonder
suffering is a drill sergeant for
awakening there's many things here
well well and it's a wonderful
experience to have is
is is as much as it seems terrible it's
wonderful it's so rich
misery is full of so many things to draw
from
i i think i think these these bad things
that happen to us get a bad rap
you know these bad periods we go through
the trauma leads to treasure
but it's important to recognize that
it is the treasure and to
dwell in the trauma is like clicking the
rewind button which is where people get
stuck along
that's where that's where i've lived
before and i've recently come out of
this sort of amen yeah you know you
can't look backwards and
don't don't look behind you when you're
on the freeway because you're gonna
wreck the car you know
it's like so that's definitely something
and to
to speak prior to what you were saying
the one thing about acting
um as a career is that it's very
it's uh there has to be some sort of
esoteric
reasoning behind it you know because
things do come to you
that's you know for the people that are
in a manifestation like things are
coming
to you so you you
the you you learn how to become very in
tune with this spiritual track
because the more momentum that you have
it wouldn't these people don't know that
you just did this and now you're happy
and
now this is coming in they have no idea
so it's it's got to be some sort of
collective unconscious is sending you
the water
you know uh sort of thing and
one thing that uh put me in a period
where i'd say it was derailed or
stagnant
was that greed was that that very
prefrontal cortex
thinking like that i can control this i
can dominate it
all that did all that sort of thinking
didn't all that all the sort of actions
that came from that
led me to uh a worse place than i
started for sure
honestly you know it's it's put me back
at least a year two years in my career
that is what is meant by
surrender yeah that is what is meant by
surrender
that wind that flow that is
the dao that is so
naturally the process
that to have those
states that you describe and it taught
you look at what it taught you look at
where you are now
in terms of what you know which is what
you're referencing okay
i want to unpack i'll ask you to unpack
something
i notice that you're out of water i'll
go get you more water oh
yeah i have to talk by myself yeah yeah
we'll give it a shot
we'll leave you for just a moment while
i fill you up on water isn't he so sweet
guys
yeah yeah gotta take care of well take
care of our guests well yeah
so the thing that where i want to go
right now
is explain to us in that first
reel and we'll get to the second reel
here in a bit in that first reel explain
to us what it's like
all of the different principal roles
and what it's like to work on the sets
what it's like to work with the writers
and the directors
okay and how they want you to fit a
specific role and so there's this
process of taking different takes and
getting better and better at that role
yeah and all this type of
of stuff how long was it for four months
or how long did it take to make
um one of these um the some of the
active creation and stuff connective
creation okay okay
i'll be right back okay so
it gets a lot harder when atlas leaves
um
shoot so the
uh so every i mean the first thing to
understand
is that every project's different every
uh
visionary behind it is different every
vision's different
and the the best thing you can do as an
actor is be in
in service to that um
you want to you want to try and bring
things to the character
that are very real you want to make the
character very real for you
you want your body to believe that this
is really happening
and you want to justify so let's say
that you're doing it one way
the director comes in and goes oh tyler
that was amazing but do it completely
different because it needs to be more
like this
so one one goal that you should have
uh especially when you're on set which
is an
uh lesson i learned the hard way um
you should do what they want them to and
justify it in your process
you need to make that you need to you
need to backwards engineer
what they're saying right so they're
saying you know this guy's more like
a wishy-washy kind of dude well where
would that even come from well where
would that come from maybe he's like his
dad right and maybe instead of his dad
being like he thought his dad worked at
a bank maybe instead his dad was like a
yoga instructor or something
you you whatever your process is you
you want to conform to that director but
i'll also say
most the directors i've liked working
with the most are very hands-off on
performance
they might say something like faster or
look here when you say this
but it's not necessarily going to be
like oh you should emphasize this word
instead of that word
most the ones that uh and they've
typically
been the ones to go on and be more
successful are the more hands-off
directors
yeah and that's why it's so important
for the actor to have such a strong
process
and uh strong people to work with
coaches and all that
because it really that that really is
your job
you know it's it's not when you're on a
set everything needs to be going
as fast as possible you only have
like uh we rented out sayers club for
one of those that's like a 25 000
day if that date goes wrong the
production's out you know
25 grand so
um yeah you should just bring it bring
your bring your best
work and hopefully they like it
yeah damn within the budgets so there's
things like
renting out a venue for a day and making
sure that everybody's hella on point
that day
yeah to capture the specific scene that
you're well the pressure is real
you know they're sometimes you're like
oh god
if i [ __ ] up this if i mess up this line
one more time i am ruining this whole
thing right like if i
if i don't get this the whole scene
might have to go
that's going to be terrible for me so
that pressure's there that's why
being able to sort of at will turn off
your prefrontal cortex is like
the first skill you should hone as an
actor is being able to just shut
everything out
be in your body you know an actor should
really rely on their body a lot more
than their brain
exactly i think yep
in a sense that's what thank you by the
way yeah you're super welcome
in a sense that's what the flow is
and that's what the you know the body
is the portal to the formless to the
unmanned investigation
and so it's not like the prefrontal
cortex is the portal
no prefrontal cortex is its own
animal that's used for important
contributions the best trick the
prefrontal cortex did
the best trick it ever played was
convincing you
that it was your identity and not a tool
there you know it's so easy to think
that this thinking
mind i have is me but in essence it's
this
it's this little part of your brain and
now
the science even backs us up your gut
has its own it's your gut has its own
way of thinking that's why people say go
with your gut they don't say go with
your head they could say go with your
gut you know
if you need to do something
instinctually your heart your heart
thinks before your brain in a lot of
situations
so that's the biggest trick that part of
the brain ever played it was like no you
i am you this part of me is you but it's
not it's
our strong arguably one of our strongest
tools
yeah but it's just that it's only a tool
yeah
and that's typically where we get sucked
into the egoic
separate entity as well the
lack of the intuitive knowledge
of eternity versus that sort of
prefrontal
physical separate biologic creature
yeah style of thinking also what came up
was
it would be interesting to hear about
how often it's guys that get into the
trap of the
pfc prefrontal cortex exactly guys have
that linear
thinking brain this the latter brain
so i think it is easier for us to end up
in that
female gets embodied into the role yeah
and from what i understand and maybe
this is old science or bad science but
from what i
understand the the female brain
is more like a spider web so it's they
they have access to all these different
parts of their brain
at the same time easier than a guy a
guy's brain is kind of tick
tock tick tock and a woman's just kind
of like it's more like there's a spider
web shooting out and
all those pathways can connect to each
other a lot easier than men
and then that's the the yin and yang
which also
have the little the
fish eye in each of them as well
so you have the little you have the
little eye
inside the black eye inside the white
and you have the white eye inside the
black
right and so that's where you get into
this that's why
we when we embody that flow
i was on airplane mode earlier i'm just
oh yeah yeah no worries yeah really
quick
yeah yeah no worries sorry yeah good
cash yeah you're good oh no it just went
off so i was like okay
yeah yeah sorry about it yeah you're
good
the eye inside of so what what is that
supposed to reflect well
it's supposed to reflect that the
even within the dark there's light even
within the light there's dark
and so it would be something like
even within something as
i see what you're saying so something as
horrible as hitler
or here's here there are actually some
examples that we've been
kind of using for a bit about this it's
like
in science yeah
there's the perverse
morality that unfolds with things like
creating
nuclear weapons right and then
the little kind of eye of of
spirituality
is something like anchor that
god realization so that you don't make
nukes
and in spirituality it would be like
you make something like snake oil
and so science would be like the little
eye
in spirituality that is saying
don't peddle things like snake oil
to profiteer off of people saying that
this is going to help
them right make your hair grow back or
stuff like that make it 10 feet tall
taller
exactly exactly yeah yeah so another
good question to ask you about this
would be that
what's the sort of scope of
like give us your scope of interest
as well as what it is kind of generally
for these different roles that you play
in
where it's like everything you mentioned
from even a short
ad a day five figures
to a this is the most money i've ever
made by the way was that happening
so it's so awesome and then all the way
to things like
you know a couple weeks of shooting
versus a couple months
the shooting and what's the sort of
process of showing up every day
i know you gave the example where it's
like you know you have a line
on that one day at a venue and you have
to nail it
so that the scene's not taken out well
like the first scene in that reel
right yes that's that that's at sayers
club and there's a bunch of scenes there
that was
that was one of many i think the other
reel has one in the scenes at sayers
club so that that
so um baby yeah
it's as as glamorous as it seems it's a
little more
blue it's not as blue color as you know
they'll make it out seem like
at the variety round table but it is
it is a little more blue i mean blue
collar
i mean typically shoot days are like 12
hours sometimes 16 hours
almost never eight hours you're you're
always at about the 12 to 16 mark
um you usually get there either at 7am
or 7pm
like i shot a project you get there at
7pm
well to shoot till 7am so like when if
there's a scene in the dark
yeah or or two scenes in the dark in the
movie you're going to shoot those out in
one night so you're gonna get there at 7
pm shoot all night and then leave at 7
am
or 9 am um i actually worked on a
project
that had us driving around all over
california oh hi
orange sunshine it's really cool check
it out it's on amazon
um we were driving ojai laguna beach
all over california and usually you'd
get up at like three
show up at about i'd show up at about
like six you
get in here and make up at about seven
and then you leave it about like
seven eight pm and then so then after
all that
these days where you're waking up at
three then the next week
there was this studio that you can rent
out cheaper if it's at night so
you're kind of seeing where i'm going so
we yeah i go to bed at 7 00
p.m on friday saturday sunday
i was smart i started adjusting my
sleeping schedule as best i could
and then the next week the shoot was
from 7 p.m till 7
9 a.m because the studio is cheaper at
night
so usually you're just trying to be as
flexible as possible
and typically when you're working on
film you have like
very little time for anything else at
least in
a bigger a higher capacity you know a
lot of parts in
movies are a day or two you know you
show up for a day and
sometimes it's a half day but like these
these leading roles these principal role
the
the leading the main guys the it's
you're it's an all day every day
day in day out monthly thing yeah like
seven days a week
uh no because so sag said that that's a
no-no so five days five hours
sag is the screen actors guild screening
so it's our union
it's the union yeah it's the union um
and yeah that's one of their many
protections you also get
you know that's why you get overtime on
sag stuff so if
like if you do a project at 300 a day
is your rate and in a typical day you're
gonna make like
500 because you're going to be there for
12 hours
it's based on how long you're there yeah
yeah
and then it's interesting so then your
seg limits it to what five days in a
week five days on two days off yeah
yeah because so then you have something
that you can do in those two days yes
yeah relax and yeah and and uh
hopefully it's a good use of your time
you know um whatever you do on this damn
that is
that seven p.m to 7 a.m shift is crazy
it's it's so worth it though though what
blows my mind is that crew does it
because they work so much harder
like that crew works really hard yeah
acting is just you get
you i mean so getting the gigs is a
living nightmare but once you have the
gig
it's like lit it's like royalty compared
to what poor crew
like what crew goes for their own yeah
you know like
i that 7 p.m to 7 a.m
i probably spent most of my time
chilling out in like some corner
you know on my phone or whatever just
waiting to be told what to do
whereas someone a gaffer or something's
running around like it's an amazon
fulfillment center
all night so exactly i don't know it's
it's crew's working really hard
yeah even principal roles get these
breaks throughout the 12 hours and
when they when they move the camera or
whatever they send you off it takes like
half an hour
it takes like half an hour to move the
camera get all the lights and everything
right it takes forever
it takes forever to shoot one scene i
think the average
when i moved out here and learned this
the average was like four minutes a day
is what people shoot like four minutes
of actual footage footage
it's probably higher than that now with
all the technological advances
yeah but yeah you're you're getting very
limited amount of time per day a lot
less than you would think
yeah those those cuts
that you were showing us were really
strong in your
reel the the cuts were really
really well done where you know
even in that first one where you know
she was saying
you know baby and you were walking in
right it wasn't it wasn't her it was
the video was on you while she was
saying it so like i'm just saying it's
good to see
sort of the you know every couple of
seconds is even if you're talking it's a
switch from
you know this angle on you to this angle
on you that's something i did
intentionally
and then you finish the sentence and
before you even finish it the camera's
already on her
awaiting what she says next and then
cutting to your reactions
that's really strong filmmaking yeah
and that's that's probably um
that's that's more than likely the
editor but there are some cuts in there
so since that's the real i'm sending out
for myself um
to try and get jobs i'm cutting out the
other people as much as i possibly can
so that's why some of the cuts might
seem unnatural i'm just cutting out
everything that's not me in the scene
uh and in that first scene it's so much
about their relationship and their
dynamic i leave a little bit more
with her but yeah but um
yeah that's really good filmmaking it's
j and l cuts which is basically like
if you were talking if i were talking
talking talking cut to your reaction
before i ended the sentence that's
pretty
that's pretty um standard standard yeah
yeah and
what does the j and l stand for j goes
that way
and then l goes that way so like they're
overlapping
so uh uh a j cut
is gonna overlap backwards how does it
make sense
like if you have the two clips on
premiere yeah and it's like that
that's a j cut and then if it's like
that that's an outcut
i see they're they're overlapping with
each other i see what you're saying
that's cool j
l cuts now i'm following kyle taught me
that yeah how's taught me a lot
yeah i i think we even talked about jnl
cuts a little bit with kyle on the show
probably yeah those are those are really
good
um techniques techniques yeah yeah
editors make it seem like film
well yeah and editing is just um
it's another unsung hero you know i
think the three most important people to
the like actual creation of a movie or
the writer director and the editor
you know those are the the editors just
a little slept on
i think yeah the writer director and
editor and then also the crew
the actors and actresses and the audio
the
um yeah audio engineering and the
mastering of the final
audio goes into the video which is the
editing
editor eddie oh yeah i was like do you
know some word i don't
i don't know the editing yeah yeah and
it usually takes the longest
as opposed yeah yeah production is all
the fun stuff
it's post where i've done some of that
like
i've done some editing work um and it's
way
harder it's so it's so tedious bro yeah
that you have post
why do we do these live yeah yeah
exactly right you're editing on the fly
actually look like a wizard he's doing
all this
um yeah i worked for a
production house as an assistant editor
on the emmys one year
it was the in memoriam we were working
like 60 to 90 hour weeks
like just editing exactly it's horrible
yeah it's hard
sitting behind the computer it kills
your eyes it kills your eyes it kills
your
your yeah typing does that
typing mouse uh i had to switch to
ergonomic
going this way as a mouse instead of
flat i've seen that it hurts
yeah and then my my cousin's a
screenwriter his carpal tunnel he's
30 maybe his carpal tunnel is just crazy
it'll
ruin his whole day he'll get bad carbs
exactly you know
exactly computers are as great as they
are as a tool they're not very
body-free well we're about to get to
where it's in that augmented reality
environment and it's as simple as just
clicking and dragging or even thinking
with the neural link
yeah i hope so and then and then all the
creativity is a lot easier
and all these jnl cuts and all this
audio mastering and
even just look at so i not a lot of
people know this i guess
the way they used to edit movies was
they would hang all the strips of film
from the ceiling
yeah yeah for the scenes and they'd look
thrown a magnifying glass and
they it's a cut because they would
literally cut the film and then splice
it back together
that's so annoying i would never do that
you couldn't pay me a billion dollars
to edit citizen kane all these strips of
film and i'm going around
and then you have to sync the audio up
which is done on a freaking eight track
you know the the fact that you know
someone is
is um that was the cutting edge though
bro oh
they were like whoa we're gonna sync
sound ups movies even when they shot
it was completely different you would
have people that are off screen
screaming on the scene because they
didn't
the the computers just changed the game
the fact that i can learn how to edit
you know in a few years is it just
speaks to it you just have to
spend years and years and that's on the
side you know i'm learning how to do it
i'm doing it as a hobby
the so hopefully that next advancement
is putting it out in front of you
iron man style you know in the iron man
movies he's always like grabbing the arm
putting it with his chest
exactly this i just want to do this and
make a movie and make a movie yeah
exactly
yeah exactly i think everyone does so
but then but then everyone in my
industry would be out of a job everyone
make their own movies
well in a sense it would create an even
stronger
compression algorithm for
the most creative things to rise to the
top
just kind of in a sense what like social
media
is is that it's kind of like especially
like tick tock and one not it's just
created a
a compression like you need to be able
to package something in 15 seconds and
put it out there in a way that hopefully
gets people to recognize it but there's
it's a big difference between making a
tick tock video
and a feature film in a feature film
yeah unfortunately
a lot of people are choosing the 15
seconds over the two hours but
i don't think features are going
anywhere
i uh so when i first moved out here i
would sneak because the
15 seconds is way less of a
time investment yeah yeah exactly
and so people do that whereas the two
hours you can tell a much more profound
story but it's a
more well and i guess i'm the one that
would argue you know and
i'm not arguing with you the argument
yeah is that
two hours of 15 second videos has a lot
less
uh uh is a lot worse use of my time
and you won't two hours exactly you
won't learn [ __ ] either you ask
people after they are on the platform
looking for two hours at 15 second
videos
ask them an hour after they get off the
platform
tell me one thing that you learned while
you were on the platform
yeah and i mean there there are
exceptions versus versus mostly
yeah it's mostly entertainment and not
edutainment
yeah and a film is mostly trying to
convey a profound message of some sort
well the other thing that films do um
and now
you know now culture is doing it in its
own new ways but the one
one thing that films do who teaches you
really how to speak
throughout your life if you're how to
speak eloquently how to how to behave in
a certain way i mean those are really
all films the reflections
of life we see that and we emulate that
behavior it's and
filming that way acts as a teacher you
know yeah and
and you can learn these lessons
hopefully the easy way i always say
film is a safe place to deal with
dangerous things
you know to to experience uh things like
like um that film beautiful boy
i feel like it does a really good job of
conveying as much as a film can
the the absolute devastation that
addiction can be on a family
you know and hopefully every now and
then
we learn a lesson through film that we
don't have to learn the hard way
yeah it's probably also a good time to
talk about the
transition as you were kind of
explaining how there's all those
strips of film that then magnifying
glass and you cut
so basically literally like okay i think
i'm gonna do it before he squinches
yeah cut yeah exactly and then
that also kind of was part of the in the
past
it was a lot more about singing dancing
and acting was the trifecta
yeah so back in the day you know you're
fresh-faced show up to new york hey
where do i you know whatever
um yeah you were kind of expected to
know how to sing how to dance and how to
act
well the new the new trifecta going
around hollywood is
write produce act you know those are the
three things that
uh if you're gonna become a master of
any three things as an actor i guess
those are the three that you're supposed
to do
and if you look at it if you go to imdb
look at leonardo dicaprio's
um imdb page he's produced more movies
than he's acted in
george clooney's produce more movies
than they've acted in
the you really want to be if you're
doing film you really want to
this is something i'm trying to
challenge myself to get better at you
really want to learn how to produce a
film
so so that firstly you can tell the
stories that you want to tell you can
make the parts for yourself that you
want to make
yeah you know and that's it gives you a
lot of agency over your career
but also in terms of breaking in if you
can write produce and act in a film
you can give yourself that breakout and
so that's
that's something that i know i'm trying
to get better about i've been doing a
lot of writing i'm trying to figure out
the producing
um and yeah that's the new trifecta
you know mgm musicals don't what la la
land
did well over the past 10 years but
that's like the only musical that's come
out
yeah that's probably one of the most
common resonances for me as well of
being here is doing a lot of writing of
this
animated series chimps we're working on
and all these other kind of docs and
anthologies and all these other types of
things
yet the production side of it is where
people like kyle come in that are just a
lot
stronger on those kind of j l cuts and
just getting all these other kind of
things
together so to sort of learn the ropes
even though we can do this sort of live
setup of a podcast is great but it's not
like
that editing that we were talking about
that really
draws together the audio and the video
into something that is so profound
and on an acting level i'm definitely
getting some of those ropes as well
which is very fun
you're getting lots of credits in many
ways and in this sense this is we're
approaching our 720th
interview yeah and we're also
approaching
our sort of my essence becoming more and
more
like completely free in the sense of
like
expressing a like characters and play
and that kind of a thing a lot more
fluidly and dynamically so i'm kind of
getting some of those ropes so
i'm totally feeling like la's vibe kind
of landing more and more
in our kind of soul of the show as well
and then yeah well that that's that
makes sense
yeah exactly because we're rubbing off
on each other like in the sense of like
the show
simulation the ethos of bringing these
biggest questions about metaphysics
non-duality consciousness to the hearts
of these different influencers and
celebs
well it's it's no la's also rubbing off
on us with writing producing acting
right well it's no it's no coincidence
you move to the entertainment capital of
the world
um and out of nowhere how do we get our
message across let's do it through
entertainment
you know exactly those those things
don't one thing about la is it's it's
kind of like a pressure chamber
you know it's it's literally where stars
are born there's so much pressure
under it there's there's so much
compression that i think if you survive
it long enough you come out
a pearl you come out a diamond or
whatever but a diamond and
yeah and the you know the intense
pressure and temperature that diamonds
form under is very much like the humans
themselves
we also are naturally from
our birth a diamond yet
it's up to us to require that we to
register to recognize that we are
that diamond that already is yet of
course we gain a lot more
wisdom and insight as we go on
now um this would probably be also a
good time to
play our second
uh oh yeah let's uh yeah we'll play the
second asset this one
um oh i do want to just introduce one
thing
yeah yeah so the first bit
is is a collaborative effort between
kyle shadow and i
and it's really just a test i was hoping
to
show more but as the california went
back into another lockdown we we
couldn't get as much done as we wanted
but so one thing that we're doing he and
i
is we're gonna start to make uh like
minute
videos for new actors i was saying
earlier like good footage goes a long
way
especially in the beginning of your
journey so
one uh what we're gonna start to do is
we're gonna start to
cater to whoever's you know paying for
it and make
a minute segment for their demo reel
that way that you
you know you can show agents casting
directors what it is that you're capable
of
in a professionally shot way but this is
this is a test we ran um and
it's gotten a lot better since so
hopefully we can show it off again later
um
okay over there
don't move
i don't want to hurt you okay but
there's some people out there
that want to hurt me very bad and if you
do anything i mean
anything to tell them where i am i will
have to shoot you
now what's your name jamie
record deal they want me to tour make an
album the whole
shebang future isn't finished you know
there we go
thanks babe yeah all right
i'll see you guys how do you know i was
at zombiecon
yeah but i didn't kill him and i wasn't
the only one he pissed off
what do you mean some other guy followed
kendall
outside maybe one of his marks i don't
know i figured he'd teach ken a lesson
for me too
can you describe this guy about my age
skinny tattered clothes his makeup
was super elaborate anything else
and he had a limp doesn't everyone have
a limp at zombie gun
yeah when you're in character and when
you're ducking out the back door to kick
the guy's ass that just robbed me yo
does lacy know you're going to this
party
is
why the [ __ ] would i ask you to come
with me don't
try to make yourself the victim in all
this i mean the two you [ __ ]
happily ever after
[Music]
yeah the nuances there are
unique and
also similar to that first one well
they're there i used two bits from
uh the same from two to the same project
one of the one of the problems when
you're building um
a career is you end up doing a lot of
stuff that you just kind of cut out
so i i like those two projects that i
used again
in particular for those scenes but the
approach with these two reels was to
have one that's like the drama and one
that's comedy
so i took the lighter elements of those
projects and put them in
the lighter reel and then the darker
elements and put them in the darker reel
because i see you usually only send one
video ac to a casting director
exactly so if the character is like
murderer or a criminal
i would send that second one if the
character's like cute guy
kissing hot girl i'd send that first
first one yeah
perfect that makes perfect sense yeah
yeah that but that's why there's that
cross
with the projects yeah because there's a
lot there's some other stuff
so then there's the differences in the
similarities because yeah
from the same project yeah yeah but like
the guy's kind of being an [ __ ]
instead of being nice that guy's kind of
being an [ __ ] instead of being nice
well
if the guy's an [ __ ] and he's
screaming at a chick in the thing we'll
just show
the [ __ ] parts yeah yeah um
nice yeah you know you you want to use
the best of what you have and you want
to keep it short
so a lot of stuff i've done uh just
frankly isn't in any of my stuff because
it just
doesn't um doesn't look as good for the
most part
or the right exactly yeah so
yeah yeah it's like kind of looking back
at our interviews from like three years
ago
yeah right yeah that's not your best
foot don't put that forward
that didn't happen keep it on the resume
but don't go look at it please
yeah i did this one it's called train
robbery three
you know yeah like yeah it's funny
it's funny looking back at you know your
acting from three years ago and
you know my interviewing from three
years ago it's funny but yeah you're
right it's cool to tailor your reels to
the different
casting yeah well as as everyone's
attention
span gets shorter casting directors do
so you want you don't want to make them
spend four minutes
my the reels i use now are half half as
long as either of these they're like a
minute long
because if they're watching 300 people
and you're the dude that's thing is like
three and a half minutes you're kind of
just the [ __ ]
you know like you just
give them the best minute you got and
hope for the best really or two minutes
two minutes it was about the cap exactly
yeah one to two minutes of the
compressed best of your
acting yeah so now what my now what my
the page that my reps use to send out
for me
it's about nine clips not not
not two reals not one real it's about
nine
small clips they're all like 10 seconds
or a minute a minute yeah
they're all 59 seconds exactly so
they're all as tailored as specific
to this is like a rom-com vibe kiss kiss
kiss girl girl girl kiss kiss kiss
okay this is dude with a gun dude with a
gun
dude and dude with another gun you know
yeah
it's all it's all really specific and
tailored exactly
drama versus comedy yeah well and even
more there could be drama like
guy who's in a relationship and it's
tough or a drama guy who's taking your
car
so there's thug then there's like
dude going through it in a movie about
relationships
so you want to segment that as much as
possible and that's why there's those
nine
clips yeah as opposed to like two big
reels
one i know people i know a guy's got a
12 minute reel because
you know he's from you know a long time
ago
it was when he was you know having to
send his reel out
he doesn't really have to as much
anymore but so i see his real it's like
12 minutes long
because it's just changed so much yeah
this idea of these individual clips is
is maybe five years old yeah they come
in they kind of like a la
carte select from a buffet of what
is what essence you've been able to
represent as an actor and if you've been
able to represent these different
essences really well
then in a sense you're more like a
synthesis like that joseph and the code
of many colors
yeah like um okay i'm i'm looking for
parts
and i see a character his name's bob and
bob's a drug dealer and he's selling
crack
do they need to see me you know hang out
with my girlfriend on the couch
probably not they probably need to see
the guy who's
playing with the gun while he's driving
and then the guy who's like
i wasn't stealing nothing that's all
they need to see yep to know that you're
good fish
that's that buffet yeah that buffet
style yeah that's interesting
you know just saying what they need it's
kind of like you know we do this
interview on acting and filmmaking and
then somebody else can go and listen to
another interview we did on
consciousness and non-duality
specifically
right right it's like okay well you know
atlas's ability to sort of navigate
those different
landscapes of conversations right and
even more when they're selecting it you
have them all
this one's about this this one's about
this exactly so that's all that you're
doing with
the materials you're sending in exactly
yeah yeah i love that sort of buffet
style approach it's kind of like what
the channel looks like in terms of like
the landing page of the channel with all
the different playlists
the service that you use to get acting
jobs in terms of the video content is
very similar so you'll send one picture
you'll send one video
then when they click on it they'll see
all your pictures unless you omit some
you can omit as many as you want they'll
see all the pictures headshots
they'll see all the videos and if they
want to watch all the videos they're all
there
what is that service called it's called
uh breakdown ex
uh breakdown express is the agent's
version and then the actors is called
actors access
actors access actors access yeah so if
you're an aspiring actor
sign up now it's like 100 bucks a year
yep and then they charge you for
everything every picture you put on
it's it's not a cheap pursuit
but it's cheaper than opening a
restaurant
so as soon as they click on the image of
your headshot it's going to open up the
other 20 headsets that you have yeah
whatever you don't omit
yeah yeah because you can be like i
don't need i don't want but you're
uploading and you're paying for
everything yeah you pay it's like 22
bucks a picture
22 bucks a minute per year no
just to put up and then per year if
you're sag it's like 60 bucks
and then if you're not sag it's like
100. yeah so
that's that's one of the benefits i
guess and do you just sign up for
sag or how do you get into the union you
have to do a certain amount of union
jobs
yeah um i wouldn't recommend joining
unless you have to like uh that show
i did i had to you have to
yeah well if you do so the holocaust
there's many like us the holocaust film
that put me in
eligibility so i could have paid for it
then
my agent uh having my best interest at
heart
told me to wait i did a certain amount
of sag projects and then
i booked another sag project but before
i could do it all right dude you gotta
join
you can either join sag or not work with
sag yeah
yeah it was like it was literally like
it's like three thousand six hundred
dollars something like that
dude yeah there's uh
and then what's the sort of what's the
sort of process for
you know like doing things like getting
listed on
imdb um so
at least for me it was they put me
uh some one of the first projects i made
they were like we're gonna put it on
imdb
and then you pay them i don't even know
how much
i just there's a lot of webs
basically there's a lot of websites you
pay a lot of money to be on all of them
yeah yeah so i don't know what it sounds
a lot like
i think it's pretty cheap yeah it sound
it's like um
it sounds a lot like the social media
reach
with the programs and stuff yeah well
yeah an imdb
you the the main reason an actor uses it
is because if you have imdb pro
which is the actor's version yeah you
every agent in town you can get their
email
you know everyone's email and stuff is
on there so it's mostly to chase down
reps chase down directors get their
emails harass them
and what are you usually trying to
message them like that
so it'd be a good idea to get imdb pro
like if we're also wanting to interview
some of these
leaders yeah absolutely absolutely imdb
pro
is going to give you access to all kinds
of
maybe not who you're looking for but
whoever represents them
yeah you'll be able to get their name
figure out what their phone number is at
the very least
usually you can get at least their
assistant's email through it it's it's
it's good in industry thing because it's
got it's a directory of all their
contact information exactly yeah
also let's say like i'm looking for an
agent i really like
so and so from this and that the tv show
the actor
i can look them up figure out who their
agent is and try and get them
yeah you know so if you're building a
list exactly yeah
yeah yeah cool cool
and then so amazon bought
the rights to there is many like
i think so um yeah or so
some of this was published like five
years ago yeah so our premiere
was in 2015 and i i don't know
why it says 2020 but i'm glad it does
because people
we'll we'll see it some more um it's
like the first project i worked on out
here
uh it's it's like a documentary
narrative drama
um it's on amazon but yeah so i don't
know exactly what happened
but we had a release in 2015. i don't
think it did particularly well
it did pretty well in europe from what i
heard and then i'm
i'm assuming that the distribution
company sold
the product to amazon because the
director
likely sold the product to the
distribution company
and then the distribution company like
sold the product
to amazon because they're all assets
like they play with them just like
when businesses buy up you know when
coca-cola buys
m m's from costco or
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah but it's
it's a really
cool story it's the story of um
a guy and a girl they meet in a
concentration camp
and uh they go on this crazy journey
they end up together outside of the
concentration camp they reunite later
i don't really want to give it away but
it's it's pretty impactful it's told by
the grandson
of those two yeah which is
of of max in particular yeah yeah
and i play max and he breaks out of the
holocaust
yeah the the the project
the like uh what would you call it code
name was escaping the holocaust
and then this came through the
production of the project
the director was like oh no i'm gonna
call it there's many like us
yeah for specific reasons that are in
the film
yeah yeah yeah but it's great it's great
the end of that second reel where i
kissed the girl in black and white
that's what it's from
exactly yeah yeah yeah and i need to get
my post i need to get a poster
yeah and even the
the sort of dynamic of
like in the dramas you know this one has
it's also
deep drama but it's not related to guns
no and that's kind of interesting as
well so there's like the gun
you know one minute clip that's up there
or like two or three of those because
you have several of those
yeah that's i guess i look like a
criminal this
i pretty much this is just kind of a
funny side now
for the past like year or two i've
pretty much exclusively gone out for
rapists and killers
like uh there were actually two movies i
just got really close to at the end of
last year they were both
serial killers basically so i guess
that's my
i'm wondering if like in a past life i
was like a rapist serial killer or
something because
i my energy seems to attract that kind
of work well that that first
clip that in the second clip and the
first part of it mm-hmm
right that's a pretty strong yeah right
that's like
yeah yeah yeah i guess you get good at
what you practice yeah yeah yeah
so and i wonder if there's also some
part of it like
actors and actresses sort of feel like
well
maybe that is not so much my vibe is the
sort of
serial killer rapist i think i think
whatever they think your vibe is you
should just embrace it
and keep trying to get them yeah
interesting like the last part i played
in the film was in 2019
and he was like dealing coke to a high
schooler
the dude so i guess a bad guy kind of
thing
and then last year i did a zoom play in
new york so that's kind of interesting
thing to come out of coronavirus was you
know you don't usually get to do theater
in new york
from la but because they were doing it
all over zoom i was like hey can i join
in
and that guy was a rapist so i guess so
i guess that's my gosh yeah it's
interesting
you can find the links in the bio below
to the different
films we're talking about and tyler's
pages
and also we yeah look at me on imdb it
helps my
there's a there's a stat there's a
there's literally statistics
on imdb that really help actors if you
search them
um on imdb specifically it'll really
just boost my rating
you don't have to read anything click on
it it'll it'll help me out in the long
run
it'll help me get more jobs yeah that's
so interesting yeah the clicks yeah
yeah it's fascinating so
uh another thing that we didn't touch on
yet but we did
in that first session yeah was sort of
um
no worries this is the link again in the
bio to tyler's uh instagram
you have a coach one of the coaches
that's been helping you a lot robin dale
myers
yeah she's wonderful and so um
walk us through sort of like part of
like that
learning process for you on how to
like what is being taught and how you're
incorporating it
yeah so i've had a lot of coaches um
throughout the years
um i have no idea how many but it's been
it's been enough that i don't know like
one a year
oh at least at least you know i went to
i did
a few conservatory programs where i'd
have six or seven at the same time
sometimes eight so a lot of coaches um
are teachers i guess she's a teacher and
a coach
and robin so
there are two people i've learned a lot
from there's lisa robinson
and she teaches it's called it's scene
study it's a type of the pursuit
and she is a hard ass if you don't do
your work
if you don't and you show up to her
she's gonna be like why are you wasting
my time you didn't put enough hours into
this you know
and then you know she wants she wants
the best for all of her
uh students and her clients um
but robin has this uh extreme compassion
about it
and one thing that she taught me how to
do
uh is audition well there's a big
difference between acting and
auditioning
and and it's it's interesting you have
to learn acting to even start to learn
how to auditioning to uh how to
how to auditioning how to audition you
have to start you have to know how to
act to even start to learn how to
audition
but you have to audition to get acting
jobs
so they're kind of inverse of each other
and what she teaches is basically what i
was talking about earlier that the body
doesn't know the difference between
true and true reality in the imagination
so if if i have a strong relationship to
someone that's completely fictitious
but i've gone through the process of
creating memories with that person
i'm inherently gonna feel some great
pain if i lose them or something
and she teaches this whole technique
around
each line individually in the script to
give you that real
realistic visceral experience and
if you if you really get good at the
process you could
have five pages down it's memorized
because it's in your bones
real reactions within like two or three
hours so
if you're at a spot where you're like i
can act but i don't know how to audition
i would definitely recommend studying
with robin
she's at the marjory margie haber studio
yeah and margie avery is
one of the all-time greats but whoa yeah
robin's my
my favorite yeah yeah whoa so there's
studios where there's kind of like
groups of coaches
there's people just making money man
yeah i mean yeah there's
there's studios so margie haber um she
worked with like brad pitt
she's a big big name in the acting class
world
she's a huge coach um and robin's sort
of a protege
per se yeah and yeah i i love her style
be fun to explore getting
robin on the program that could be i
could try i'll ask her yeah that could
be fun
oh she's you've never met anyone so kind
in your entire life
she's just full of love she's i love
that yeah the compassion
yeah yeah um yeah but lisa robinson
she she's larry moss's disciple larry
moss is leonardo dicaprio's coach
guy costs like six hundred dollars an
hour i think he's
it's not cheap um i don't think it's
that much i think it's like 800
a month but uh or a thousand
but she is like you can do better than
this
you're like i can she's like yes and
then
eventually you get there she she puts
you through the ringer but it's more
that's more role prep right so there's a
big difference between auditioning and
role prep so
if you get the part now you've got to
build a whole life around these 130
pages
that's a very different task than
auditioning audition is i got
three to 14 pages and i got to make
these work by tomorrow
and then role prep is okay in three
months we're shooting this i want the
best possible character
yeah got it yeah got it auditioning is
for the casting call
yeah and then the role prep is for when
the camera's on
yeah yeah yeah and that's its own beast
exactly and if you have the money that's
when you have to have it in every bone
like you were saying yeah yeah you your
whole essence
when you have a project you really want
to i mean
it's it and it's so competitive and so
much and you want to do so well
there was an audition i had last year i
lost 15 pounds in prep for the callback
i literally just fasted i yeah i fasted
and i just ran
i was like i just made my cal not 15
maybe 10.
i made my calorie deficit like 2500 to 3
000 every
day um because
if i got it we were gonna start shooting
a week later and the character was thin
so um yeah you look really good right
now
so was it this weight or was it ten
pounds lighter no it was lighter than
this it was like damn
that's really old yeah yeah i was eating
like nothing i was eating
my wife is vegan really good at
nutrition
and stuff so she made sure i was getting
all my nutrients it was just no calories
so it was just mostly vegetables
that i was eating for like two weeks and
then i just like run
and do high intense yeah workouts
yeah hit damn and that was just in prep
in case i got the part that's how that's
how competitive it is you're like
if i can lose 10 pounds by the callback
my chances are that much better
yeah yeah yeah
i know it's so insane yeah
have we hit on all of these kind of
as many of the different faces of the
mountain of acting and filmmaking like
has it been a pretty good
it's been good yeah yeah we could um we
can transition a little bit yeah
okay let's transition okay let's do it
all right
so let's start with some of the more
uh simple questions sure do we
actually let's ask it this way what is
your source
my source it's everyone
consciousness consciousness
i i was talking to my brother about this
last christmas
it's it was so impactful it wasn't this
christmas it was last christmas is this
a younger brother or yeah he's my
younger brother
he's a genius um we could get more into
him later um
what started the big bang the only thing
that makes any sense to me
is that consciousness thought what if
so source is consciousness it's the
the viewer the experience
experience existing existentialism
experience is the source of all things
or the desire to experience
what about you i'm going to turn the
question around what is what is
the source it's a cool cool answer yeah
the
sort of
the i is a really good tell also
where you have things like
we just published this one
this has a lot this has a lot to do with
that i saw that
you saw this one yeah yeah kind of that
explain like i'm five
essence to coloration of experience
yeah the pupil is what is shared
right that's the eye of god there's
those chills again
but then the coloration is the
individual then
yeah the uniqueness yeah the unique
experience
yeah i personally think that there's um
source and then the organism keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller
you know so the higher the higher self
is also another being
that's independent of source so there's
stages
into the the
greater amalgamation of source you know
and i guess like
the inner rim would be gods right higher
beings closer here's another
way to unpack this the way that you what
you're describing
right now is
it's it's good and it's
part of the expression of what
this is is the sort of the
different
layers to it that
are
in a sense between you could say the
unmanifested and the manifested
between the formless and the form it's
it could be that it's not just the human
is the portal between those two
but also that there are other layers
as well 100 and so yeah like gods or
higher dimensional beings or stuff like
that stuff like that yeah
i think those have to exist although
although the most although
there is only one there's
a singularity and then the
fractal like explosion let me let me
draw yeah yeah yeah yeah actually see i
when we started this i was like i'm
never gonna use this freaking notepad
but you're 100 right this helps a lot
this is gonna help a lot
okay so you've got
you've got sores and it's this cute star
right and then you've got these
waves that go out from sores
and they go in all directions i'm not
going to switch every color
now imagine this just going off in all
directions right
now within those waves you have bodies
within those bodies you have smaller
bodies within those smaller bodies you
within those bodies you have smaller
bodies within smaller bodies
that are all all part of the same thing
like the matrix these are all part of
the source but there's
lower level lower not lower um
more specific right so you've general
truth
which is that all is one and then the
more specific you get
you have like this this frequency
creates this
creates this creates this and then it
becomes the
human being but that's part of a larger
you know you could call it your your
guardian angels or your
spirit gods or whatever but those all
ultimately end up in the same place
is kind of my thoughts
i'm a terrible this is what we just had
tyler draw momentum
someone dedicating himself to art sure
itself can't draw
so
another way of expressing it would be
something like
our awareness
is pure blank bare empty
and then it gets colored uniquely
like the individual experience yeah so
like okay you know maybe like here's you
getting this blast of colors and i'm
getting this blast of words
but what we share is the blank white
is what has the image on it yeah
okay just like the screen right right
the screen we share
but you get different images on it than
i do right but we recognize those as
modulations of the same
god as in we are sharing
the one awareness the one experience the
one experience yeah
the one experience sir or the one
witness
yeah the one observer is god
is source across all of these different
creation designs
yeah and one more layer to that is that
then even beyond
the observer being shared
so in this creation design it would be
something like from big bang until now
it's just one observer observing from
all of these different
perspectives yet it's also that
even this experience in itself is a
dream
it's still an illusion yeah
even this form that is created
is all energy well
we were kind of talking about this
outside the way that i like to explain
it or think about it
is if you took brand new software
and put it on 20 year old hardware it
would try to make sense
of what's going on in it but the
hardware just couldn't couldn't handle
it right so
everything that we see this chair and
light and
um hear sound that's all our
interpretation
of something much greater than our
hardware can handle in essence right the
brain can only handle so much truth
at once so the actual essence of
everything is
uh far more complicated and all that but
this is what we can make sense of
you know if we could see everything if
we could handle all the software of
reality if we could handle the
100 truth we we would be saying
it would be indistinguishable i i think
it would be indistinguishable what we
see
maybe we'd be seeing all of time at once
there's no way to know the more that we
slow
down the more that we gain access
like a portal into the formless which is
what you describe
and it becomes more and more clear that
that is our home
right that is what cannot ever be
threatened right and all of this that is
emerging
is an appearance an illusion a dream a
play a cosmic play a divine play
and that to know that
home is what is inward and that home can
never be threatened that home is eternal
yeah there's even the old adage home is
where your heart is
you know um
the home home is home is that the whole
idea of it is
non-physical it's it's a it's a
it's an awareness or state of being or
it's a place
but it's it's a different kind of place
it's a place you go
from here definitely i
i if if that's along the lines of what
you're saying like yeah yeah
yeah another
exploration that sort of gets people to
it is the illusion of time which we
talked about a lot as well yeah
the more that you recognize that
the more you go inward the more you
recognize eternity
and the the more that you recognize that
time and
form and physicalism in general
is a play an illusion a dream and that
it's fun to play yet
we recognize our source as we do so
so that way we're not blindly going out
thinking that i'm an egoic separate
entity that is finite and biological
but that i am an infinite eternal source
that is expressing itself
yeah i call it i call it an immortal
spiritual being
having an experience or playing a game
that's kind of how i think about it like
it's a game or it's a movie
you know the the mortal play but a game
makes more sense to me because it's got
more agency
right like yeah the mortal spiritual
soul
is doing this as an exercise it's not
necessarily true
that's just what i think personally and
the simulation thing would make sense
with that too
it's just putting ourselves in it we're
playing a game yeah
i just don't think it's technological i
think it's metaphysical
yeah very much so that
there's no other way to view
the creations then
that they are creation and simulation
being synonymous
that they have to be synonymous
and the fact that we think that it's a
computer
that's running this in some kids
basement from the future is a
funny laughable thing or some dude's car
battery
all that all that type of stuff it's
just funny it's laughable because in a
sense it's like
our source is what simulates these
yeah now are there is there nesting
yes there's absolutely nesting that
happens we are about to experience
one layer of nesting another layer of
nesting ourselves oh when we create the
simulation exactly we're
we are already creating the
indistinguishable virtual realities and
we have the neuralink technologies
and artificial general intelligence and
that's what's called the metaverse which
is the synthesis of those things
so when you go in and you play an
80-year game in one of those virtual
worlds
that is what this already is yeah that's
that's
i mean that's fundamentally what i think
it is because then you return home
there's that book many lives many
masters where it was kind of captured
that that's at least what happens that
when you die you return home and then
you
go back into the game or simulation you
know
uh the there's been a lot of instances
where there could be what some would
think of as empirical
evidence not proof evidence that
uh reincarnation happens and then people
go through multiple cycles some essence
of them goes through multiple cycles
there's there's enough evidence to
suggest that may be true
you know and then the rest is faith the
tibetan book of the dead is doing a good
job of that and
there's a lot more investigations with
the amount of weight that people lose
upon
death and there's also the yeah the 6.6
grams
yeah the contraction that people let go
as they die as they recognize that they
they are
eternal you know that's why the death
process
for those that are paying attention is
so releasing
for especially the agoa contraction
because when you are already non-duality
like right now at the age of 28 or
whatever
death is a complete illusion and so to
use it's absolute fearlessness
and so that's what home is home is that
that is the recognition that this is
vacation
home is the recognition that we share
our being and that this is an
exploration
and that it would be completely it would
be completely ridiculous for me to do
anything to a quote other which is
really the one
that is not of the highest morality you
only want to be of the highest morality
and it's a natural thing that comes
through
when you've become god realized but it
requires piercing the veil which
requires
the pursuit of external happiness
to take a back seat to the pursuit of
internal
awareness yeah you know
i i think that i think that's uh
one once one such pursuit that could
bring someone
a lot of meaning but the
the more i become comfortable with that
line of thinking
the more i look at someone who might be
more of a realist wants to live
in the real world do material things
which is still an equally valid
expression of source
yeah exactly i don't i don't want to and
that's why the non-dual tradition is
literally
everything is indescribably perfect
there is literally
nothing to do or as it should be as it
should be so there is literally nothing
to do
regarding the person that is in the
parable of the prodigal son
out seeking their external happiness
that is perfect yeah and then the person
that is literally just chilling in
formless non-duality
that is perfect right and people might
be pushed by
uh societal structures or whatever to
try to fight for the realistic things
when maybe they
they aren't necessarily meant to
planetary ecological
disharmony is another one as in
literally the force yeah
the forcing function of that is another
thing it's still perfect
it's all harmonic but the approaching
breaking point
of disharmony although this is just a
dream and illusion is still
very important in the sense of do we
want to continue
living in this dream on this planet well
that's the thing i mean if it's if it's
ultimately
you know you can you can look at it like
nihilistically oh ultimately
none of this matters or existentially
which is that
actually all of the meaning is in the
experience of it
you know which they kind of take the
same approach which is that this is
[ __ ] this isn't real but
existentialism to me
makes more uh it's more assuring
because it gives meaning to the very act
and effort of going through it that is
that's the gold that's the goal is to go
through the experience
and i think we should preserve the
breeding ground
of this experience yeah and it's it's an
it's it's very careful here because like
non-duality is supposed to
use as few words to try and describe
what the nature of reality is which is
why there's so many of these different
perennial wisdoms that are very short
that try and explain what it is with
these different signposts to the same
one truth
but in this case it would be something
like
the
the essence of the
perfection that this is
is not attributed to purpose or meaning
as in purpose and meaning are not
something that something that is perfect
needs
and so then the next thing to say is
that
now do i want to
create some illusory purpose and meaning
while i'm here
in a sense that's what people that go
externally do
what usually what happens is when you go
internally and you recognize
that the it's not even nihilism that
there is no meaning or there is no
purpose because that has so much
negative connotation it's just more that
something that's already perfect
something that's already whole
right that's not usually what nihilism
is associated with no no
exactly so and so then the
existentialist school
is interesting as well but again the
non-dual school
is even taking a step to say that
something that's already perfect
something that's already whole something
that's already completely
unconditionally free and loving it does
not
need to have meaning or purpose with
what it does therefore what this
expression is
is a dream it's illusory it's an
appearance
and it's completely anarchical and if
you want
to express yourself as
an ego's seeking something externally
perfect
if you want to if and it's not even a
want anymore either it's just what comes
through
the ego thinks that it has free will
the non-dual recognizes that free will
is an illusion
and so that's another fascinating thing
as much as like manifestation
consciousness
is like something that is interesting
for
especially for the egoic mind that's
seeking for the non-dual mind
there's an application of it that's like
what's coming through
is the fact that chimps which is the
animated series
will be manifested as it wants to
yet i'm not doing any of that it's doing
me
that's the difference yeah yeah and i
guess you know
divine purpose is where that plays into
so how much how much
agency do you think that someone in the
dance in the play has
or is there a script is there a script
and we're following the script
or is it anarchic or do you have
character agents
it's anarchy it's anarchy to the extent
that the non-dual
expresses it does you you are it
it does you and it's a
it's not deterministic so so are you
saying that the
it's anarchic not determined that
desires that people have and their
expressions of them
are aside from free will
and that people will inherently behave
in ways that make
what's going to happen happen like
if you stepped outside of time and
looked at all of it
would everything happen just as it's
going to or do you believe
that we're moving in unknown territory
and
making new decisions so
i had a good amount of understanding of
this as like a big bayesian cloud of
probabilities in the past right
that's still what i feel as though the
non-dual expression is the big bayesian
cloud of probabilities
yet at the same time i recognize that
there is no agent
there's no agent here
there's no agent there right like no
individual
there's not even not yet and not even
that there's not even an individual but
there's not even an
observer the observer in itself also
becomes transcended
because you recognize that this is the
play
if a dream of non-duality which is what
we are right we
are already starting out this is and and
now
the thing is is that
the future thing right that future idea
the future
idea is something that we in a sense
ascribe
to a in an egoic way
which is that oh we are going to have
agency and control and destiny over this
future
when all that really is is just this
so do you think that perhaps desire like
if if you want a family or something
is actually just the source's
recognition of that fulfillment later on
almost like you experience it as oh i
want to have a family
but it's more like you're going to have
a family
like is it a closed loop well what's the
eye right this is the question is when
you say i
it sounds like there's someone there
right and when i say i
there is nobody here that's the
difference when you recognize that
nobody's here
and it's just doing you family if it
happens
is something that just happens and that
it is just what
happens in the dream or the illusion
that you have family you have kids
you if you want to you can feel like wow
that's so meaningful
no problem feel whatever you want to
feel it's already perfect
it's already whole right so you it so
you as the non-dual
wake up right and then you want
breakfast there's nobody here wanting
breakfast that's right it's just
happening it's not even there's nobody
wanting breakfast
it's just that literally it happens
that's all that happens
it happens it happens there's just no
eye
so so the layers are this the individual
which is an egoic separate entity that
believes it lives in a finite physical
world of form
right the next layer is when the ego
dissolves into the ocean right the drop
dissolves into the ocean
which means like the subconscious mind
almost well in this case follow this
analogy is when you
recognize that you're not just that
egoic
but you are a observer or an experiencer
or a witness
or as the spiritual edition say you're
the i am or the self or the god
that is experiencing the waves on the
ocean
okay so now there's a juxtaposition
that's created basically
you're not lost in the words you
recognize that you
are the blank awareness page that is
experiencing the words
okay so then that's the second level up
from the egoic individual
the third level which is you can say is
the absolute
which is the top of the mountain the
second level is like the snow cap
is what usually people get to but the
third level
is the absolute which is where you say
that
even this observer itself
is transcended because this is a dream
this is an illusion this is a cosmic
play this is a divine play
of the non-dual so then what happens is
this
and this is transcended the observer and
the experience
is transcended there is nobody here this
quote here is a complete illusion
right it's just playing out it's just
playing out
and the thing is is that it really
triggers people because they
want to believe that they have agency
they want to believe that they have
something to do
they want to believe that they have
something to seek they want to believe
that they have to go and get something
in the external world
but it's already happening it's already
doing
you that's what surrender means is that
you
open your channel up because you're no
longer that contracted ego but you
recognize that you are that god source
infinite non-dual expression that is
then happening in this dream
which is oh this character whose name is
atlas
wants to do this thing where he
interviews people and he asks them about
the non-duality
yeah yeah like that's and when you get
to that level
now that's where peace and bliss
and childlike innocence and
wonder and awe are
that's when you know nothing is
threatened
because we are eternal yeah
yeah i i'm grasping i don't think i'm
getting as far down
the rabbit hole as you are but i'm
grasping what you're saying and it's
pretty wild [ __ ] i gotta say
[Laughter]
i don't know how zonked out i want to be
man
more power too yet
it's just that's wild i'm gonna listen
to that
what you just did on my phone 50 times
after this interview and still be like
the [ __ ]
it makes i get what you're saying though
this is playing out
but aren't you observing it
presently so now that's a really great
question
and it's totally where i was even just
like a couple weeks ago
yeah honestly the difference is what
happened
was that the quote
observer thought that
it existed it existed yeah the thought
that the
[ __ ] i guess that makes sense
because if we made a simulation
and the artificial intelligence inside
of the simulation
thought it existed but then
under that it was actually inhabiting
this body and the body thought that it
was the
principle there would be a stage
that the ai would get to where they
realized i'm not actually the body
i'm inhabiting the body but then they
wouldn't know
you don't even exist at all you're
running you're in my computer
right and so what we say is non-duality
or source or
god or the infinite or whatever we want
to say the eternal
that that is what that is now
i've also even played around with some
of the like science
around trying to understand well if
there was
a quote objective function
this is where i was like six months ago
i was playing around with an objective
function
like what if we were exploring infinity
what if we were exploring infinite
creation designs that's what i
kind of figure and that's what is
happening but those creation designs
don't actually have characters in them
that are experiencing experiences
that's the last step the last step is to
recognize that this
divine play of these creation designs
the the quote form the quote physical
is a complete illusion it's a dream of
appearances and that's the last step
is once you get that one that's when you
really click in
again this is fascinating because to me
this satori
towards non-duality and then into the
absolute
has just been like a month for me right
it's been nuts but i
i literally pursued truth non-stop for
five straight years
yeah until this yielded but it's
fascinating because i came to l.a
really quick is it okay if i do this
yeah i hit it yeah yeah yeah
and you come to l.a and we but we the
funny the funny thing is is that
we don't even recognize sometime
what baptizing is happening
so a month into coming into la
this baptizing happens what baptizing
satori into true non-duality
so even though before i was living at
the stage which you could call oneness
before that yeah some people would
buddha
right is buu to that stage buddha is
buddha is like nirvana buddha is
understanding the illusion
okay is what we say and jesus also we
would say is understanding the illusion
under wait before we unpack too much
there's one thing i wanted to say
yes and that's because you were talking
about the prodigal son earlier but we
were going
yeah we if you re if you
if you look at christ more as a symbol
than a person that christ represents
christ is the embodiment
of the connection between man and the
divine the the presence of jesus christ
means that we have that god in us we are
christ
so if you reinterpret the bible it's not
this separate and that's where the
church is really screwed up they took
him
exactly and they made him the separate
entity that you can never become
that's the biggest load of [ __ ] ever the
idea behind christ
is that christ is you you are the son
exactly right there's the father the son
and the holy spirit and that's the
connection between both of them which
are ultimately one
right which all of those things are the
holy trinity but they're the same thing
which is apparently nothing
and so that is what you could say
is the
last step in the mountain
is the recognition that you know of
there might be this one
well it's it's the last step but then
the thing is
is that it becomes a
more and more
to that every moment so that's the thing
is that
this now that exists right now
if we're feeling peace and bliss
and childlike innocence and awe and
wonder yeah
then that's when we've done the reps
even if you feel
the nonduality in the absolute even if
you feel that the more and more that you
basically
it's you're still going to come up like
when somebody says the word tyler
it's still going to create an onion
layer of identity
just like atlas similarly as well
there's a creation of an onion layer of
identity again
where you're basically go from the
non-dual or from the absolute
to the physical to the form to engage
with something
so when when i say you know fill up some
more water i'll go get you some more
water
you know you're thinking like okay well
this
separate entity is going to go over into
this world of form and go and procure
more water for me to fill
etc that type of thing and so it's just
the acknowledgement over time the last
the quote last step there is no last
step
the thing is is that once you get to
that mountain peak it's just about
baselining it is a last step but it's
also about
re-baselining yourself over time to be
more and more
and more of that as home as home
because your monkey mind wanders your
you fall into the illusion more and more
occasionally so well it's fun to go on
the illusion
it's fun to yeah it's fun exactly and
ultimately that's what the non-dual
tradition is gotta look at these like
billionaires ceo stuff they love playing
the game man
they love it they you know and and
that's perfect
you know so exactly well that's what's
that's what's really nice about the
belief system is that um everything's
allowed
there's nothing that's not whole there's
nothing that's not complete
already right so you're
you're sorry i'm using your because you
you know it's the perennial
i'm saying you exist but the this bodies
this thing happening in front of me your
your truth or your destiny
or your trajectory or whatever
is the path toward
understanding complete truth and living
there right
okay there's a couple layers here the
first layer is that it's
all already complete truth period it's
close
already it's all already perfect it's a
singularity that's already perfect and
whole
every aspect every appearance to it is
okay now the second layer to it which is
the dual
layer okay so the first layer is the
non-dual layer
okay all perfection the second layer is
the dual layer
okay it's a concession and what we see
in the dual layer is we say that
the egoic mind that is seeking as a
separate entity happiness externally
is creating a lot of suffering for
itself and a lot of suffering for other
people
right and so instead if that egoic
separate entity
turned inward and recognized that god
realization
what would happen is they would be
already more well-being and happiness
internally themselves
no more seeking externally but also that
they would butterfly affect that
out to their family their friends with
everything they do and they don't even
spread
and it's spread so then so that's a
that's a dual
concession to the non-dual thinking so
it's there's multiple layers to this
right and so to be able to what we call
true simultaneity
is one's ability to hold all of those
layers at the same time so it's never
just always perfection always non-dual
always but it's to be able to say okay
in the dualistic
concession seeking externally is going
to lead to unhappiness
the ego and the separate the ego of the
separate entity
and happiness cannot coexist they are
mutually exclusive positions
happiness i think so well
any any um
it would be shocking to the whole
non-dual
tradition if there was an egoic
separate entity that was that that
somehow
also knew that everything was perfect
and that they were
seeking happiness externally that would
because that would then if
that would make the egoic separate
entity completely irrelevant because
they would actually understand
the true of the perfection and they
would be the expression of it that is
seeking
external almost coincidentally right
if the ego accidentally aligned with
this divine purpose in essence
it would be a coincidence right like if
someone if that's what happened to
someone
that might that might happen that might
happen a lot you know
with with activists and stuff that might
actually happen more than we think
it has to happen or have happened
or will happen right
yes and one more thing around the
imagination
is that we go beyond this dream as in
go into all of the other dreams of
creation designs that are happening
right now
mm-hmm right so the that's the
multiverse right the multiverse yeah
exactly
i think that that all instances possible
are playing out at all given times plus
some that you can't even
plus a bunch that you can't even realize
yeah yeah
yeah it's oh yeah
and so what's up what's dreaming
dreaming is recursive what is the what
is dreaming
dreaming is recursive meaning that the
procedure calls on itself so
the the dream of the absolute being this
reality of physicalism the procedure of
this dream
calls on itself recursion as in the
illusory agents in that dream
right for a third of their life sleep
which then
has dreams create streams well you could
look at um
movies they're their dreams they're just
realized dreams
you know like they're all made up
um that's kind of what they are though i
mean most art
is a realized dream it's it's putting
some sort of physical
thing to it right it's [ __ ]
not all of them but like yeah that's
dreaming too we love to dream
i mean the plane was a dream until it
wasn't
you know it was what are you thinking
what are you talking about only angels
can fly i'm sure someone said that to
the wright brothers
so this is like
four layers past uh what i'm used to
in this ballpark no we've been crushing
it and also we were
also in the backyard it's this is uh
this is
i would say this is the core of what the
show will be
unpacking with the different on chimps
or this show yeah simulation
interviewing the different
in uh celebs influencers people here in
la
to kind of have
the introspection happen but also
with yeah with chimps and the vr
pedagogy and all these types of other
projects
is yeah getting especially young people
excited about
introspection going on the inward
journey
recognizing that diamond necklace around
their neck recognizing that well of
honey on yeah rock
and then being god realized is just a
natural flow
harmonic outward outward into the
physical dream illusion
where you would never ever do anything
that
has the that does not have the highest
morality
so you're always doing the highest
morality now from the top down
from source down right this the sense of
identity
grows and envelops and it becomes more
and more and more and more and more
why do you think that is because that is
the divine play
that is the most perfect thing that can
happen there is nothing more perfect
than the illusion of separation
that's the most beautiful thing for
something that's in essence alone
or yeah it's like uh
it's a singularity right and it would be
like
imagine if a singularity could veil
itself
from itself yeah yeah and that's what
this is that's kind of what we're
that is what this is getting at right
and there's nothing actually cool itself
as this exactly right so this is the
trick that we're playing on ourselves
yeah yeah to do yeah that's kind of
that's kind of
how i see it i guess i just never
thought it to the point that made me uh
question everything so so much but yeah
i mean
that's what i would do if i was alone
all the time i'd
get two action figures and split my
consciousness
so that i'd have a buddy right
because the essence of the center point
of all things refracted
like a prism yeah white light into all
of these different
combinations of creation designs it is
kind of like if you have ultimate truth
is the white light
hitting this creation exactly it creates
all these refractions of itself
that's wild man and that's why i put all
this stuff into
high level perception yeah right and so
that's why you're moving through it well
yeah yeah that's why you have things
like you know like this
design here which is that's why that top
you know that top left corner is that
is the prism ultimate truth refracted
becomes
all of these different combinations of
realities
that are illusory dreams that then
have these illusory separate agents
immerse themselves into it like a
symphony that only has
one attractor which is for the
recursion process to happen which is for
there to be more
exploration to happen so non-duality is
constantly
expressing itself and then creating more
and more
and more expressions of the play
of the divine there's just
so much divine play happening across
creation designs
that it's
so difficult for us to be able to
even portal inward into that
that's why when we talk about things
like the
multiverse or when we talk about things
like quantum mechanics when we talk
about all is energy
all is no thing what's happening is
we're recognizing that
there's more and more of a
on a quote atlas or quote tyler
that are across all of these different
if you slow down enough you can
basically hear the forking
if you slow down oh like when the idea
that every
time a decision is made it splits into
multiple realities right
yep yeah well that's something i i think
i mean there's so much science to back
that theory up
not to prove it but to back it up yep
that there's the
endless multiple realities yeah and that
that's the point right
whether or not you got that
correspondent this morning
but wait then wouldn't that mean that
you have some sort of agency or is that
just two different versions of the play
that it's playing out at the same time
just to see what happens it's running a
simulation is in essence what you're
saying
it wants to see everything that can
happen just to
so it's making it all happen and
but then does does that thing exist the
thing that's doing that
so it what we're talking about right now
yeah
it does not have an intention it does
not have a meaning so it's just
doing it yes
all that exists is this appearance
all that is is this appearance and all
that is not
at the same time it's all that is
and isn't and all that isn't
is two because there's
all the other appearances are happening
too
but all that there is is the one
appearance
are all the appearances but none of them
are
it's like perpetual schrodinger's cat
there you go
it's like schrodinger's cat it doesn't
matter if the bomb went off or not
because they both are happening all the
time and no one's there to witness it
nobody's here to witness this yeah
that's a mind-blowing [ __ ] man yeah
jesus
and that's the last stage so far is that
you go from the individual to the ocean
recognizing that you're experiencing the
waves
and that's and that's that's a profound
point because you get there and you're
like
holy [ __ ] this whole time i thought i
was a separate
egoic entity with eight billion other
separate egoic entities
right but now i recognize that literally
our consciousness
is the ocean and it's shared see i like
living there and
living there next spot you go to is
where is where i'm like i don't know how
much i like this next
jump you take see i like living it all
as one
isn't it pretty cool it's comfortable
for sure it's very cold this body isn't
where i begin or end but then you're
like whoa
this eye thing bro yeah which that's the
lie
which i also just got to it's not even
that it's a lie it's just that it's an
illusion it's an
appearance it's a dream the same way
that when you
well i would imply intention i guess
something so like that
when when you when you sleep at night
and you
dream you
manifest this reality
that has this character tyler's sleeping
at night in his bed
and he dreams that he's a vampire or
something
that he's a vampire that's flying
through london in the 1700s
yeah yeah yeah now does london or the
vampire or any of the experience
actually exist no
and this is okay i got you and this is
that
i got you i got you and so it's
cool for us to recognize that we are
the dream of god's source the infinite
non-duality whatever you want to call it
we are the dream of that
and it's totally cool for the dream to
express itself in all of these cool ways
just like when we dream we express
ourselves in all those cool ways right
but to not forget
that this is a dream well i told my wife
this the other day
i said what if i just kidnapped you
last night and placed all these memories
in your head
how would you know like i have this
special machine
and it replaces all it replaces all your
memories
those photos are just what happens when
your brain looks at your instagram like
what if i programmed you this way
what if you were born yesterday and i
programmed you this way do you really
remember yet like
i have these that's why they say the now
just simply
this simply now yeah because yeah do you
really i have these memories
and i'm just aware of false memories and
i go half of these have to be fake right
at least like a bunch of them a bunch of
them
not not like i'm doing it on purpose but
it's just it's so much
in your day-to-day life just to [ __ ]
live the dream
this is my this is for this is for me
just living the dream and
keep your memories you know it's easier
that way
you know i mean but i get what you're
saying it's good to kind of recognize
as far of the as much truth as you can
but it's good to live in the dream too
yep it's good
and that's why it's all perfect so this
expression
that is going oh this is the pinnacle of
the mountain have you
have you ever heard me once say that
everybody should go up this path
no that's what otherwise i'd be like hey
this guy is [ __ ] crazy
dangerous i've seen scientology yeah i
was next to that guy's a cult leader
exactly exactly and so that's that's the
fine line is when
you recognize that it's actually not
about
everybody experiencing this no exactly
it's actually this is
already perfect it's already perfect
everywhere where
everybody is have you seen tenet
movie yeah what's that about tennant
it's the new christopher nolan movie oh
oh oh that's the way that it deals with
reality is just interesting i don't know
why i'm bringing it up but
everything is a closed loop and tenant
it always happened that way it was
always going to happen that way
but they needed to participate for it to
happen that way but they were never not
going to participate
the way that they work with time in that
there's no
there's no room for agency like if you
watch i've seen it like three times now
and if you watch it there's no room for
agency the characters have
absolutely no agency over what happened
otherwise none of it would have ever
happened
because there there'd be a situation
where it didn't happen which would stop
it from happening
which you know
nolan nolan's one christopher nolan's
like
that mainstream guy that's kind of
exploring these thoughts so good
here yeah well and he's exploring these
thoughts in a visceral way
and in a way where i'm always interested
to know how much
of the perennial wisdoms of the
spiritual traditions that
they've studied because this is so
deeply aligned
with it like
kubrick's similar too but he was known
to be into this
[ __ ] yeah you know he he he spent a lot
of time on this and carl young
yep like probably the quintessential
example is
the
of this being explored in film in film
into the void
no
also with leonardo dicaprio uh inception
inception is probably the question and
you don't know if you're in a dream
ultimately you can look at that and then
the matrix is another
quintessential example of it as well the
matrix is a little more finite right
because they
but then they're in the matrix yeah yeah
exactly exactly deception and matrix are
pretty
that's another the matrix is another one
simulation theory is commonplace today
but the first time anyone heard about it
that i'm aware of was in a [ __ ] movie
he was in a movie
exactly yeah look at how that projected
and inception
he's he spins the top he doesn't care if
he's in a dream
he hits that point that's one way to
look at it i think that
exactly exactly that's
the way to answer it you don't care
anymore because you finally [ __ ] got
it
now from here on all that you do
is just be that's it now that you got it
just be
the illusion is no longer going to tempt
you
with ah come and get my physical object
because it's what's going to make you
happy
which is beautiful or or the or the
obsession of whether or not he's
dreaming
right he gives up on that because he
this is real or he lives in a dream
forever
it feels like forever because they're
stuck in the dream
they get they get out and she is so
overwhelmed
thinking she's trapped in a dream the
only way to wake up is to die
so she kills herself
now is he trapped in a dream i guess he
gets the best he gets
the best result which is um it doesn't
[ __ ] matter i'm just going to do what
i'm going to do this is fine
like this is this whatever i'm i'm sick
of again trying to
figure it out that's the wisdom and
that's the wisdom there's literally
nothing to do it's already perfect it's
already whole
see i think and then the duality is oh
they're suffering we should go and
eradicate that suffering or people
should pierce the veil and they should
real realize god you know that's the
duality
yeah it's a concession it has its truth
in its layer
yeah you kind of have to live the
duality you know
because again the simultaneity is where
you transcend
both of those into one you transcend
both of those into one
you're not doing anything there is
nobody it's
doing you it's doing you it's doing it
and the more that you
and you're just the more that you get to
that mountaintop
the more that you recognize that there
is nobody here doing anything
right but the extent to which you are
there doing it you're just along for the
ride
yeah if that well whatever the ride
is right yeah exactly that's some
trippy man we've had a good
last like 30 plus minutes talking about
this i've taken acid and not tripped out
that hard jeez
louise isn't that fascinating that these
non-dual
perennial wisdoms are more trippy than
anthogens than psychedelics yeah
absolutely that's fascinating
you can literally be quote sober and
be more high then than any entheogen
meditation has done that for me a small
handful of times
yeah likewise this many i don't know
likewise yeah
like um you don't need those substances
or meditations or anything
just get one thing they're really good
for is they do
show you they it's a good entry point
because you see that
you see the world in a different way the
gondola ride is the gondola ride
it's easier to know how to get up the
mountain when you've taken the gondola
over it
yeah you know exactly if you've seen the
top and then you're like wait i went
down there
wait why can't i get off the gondola and
then you get to the bottom you're like
i got a hike yeah i got a hike to get to
the peak
all this work and then that's usually
where most people stop exactly
they're like okay i was imagining that
so yeah yeah this has been wild which is
what happens when you take that
entheogen
and you're at the peak in the gondola
what has happened
is there a tyler no
there is no tyler no the first time i i
took a
strong anti-agenda i thought i was neil
cassidy i thought i was another dude
entirely
but that's a that's a different story i
was on the street where he was born i
was reading all the books about him the
kerouac novels and i'm like i'm [ __ ]
neil cassidy
i guess that's how that's how malleable
reality is right or your sense of self
is that given the right circumstances
and the right pick me up you won't even
think you're you you'll be like i'm this
other guy
so and that's that's what acting is it's
tricking yourself from this other guy
so in a controlled way yeah yeah
wild super awesome and i'm curious also
as to how many actors and actresses
and directors and producers and all
these people that are here celebs
influencers all these people that are
here
i'm curious how many of them have
both breached any aspects to the
investigation inward
of consciousness time duality god source
okay but as a percentage are we saying
it's like tons as in like 10
is a lot out of all of them is that what
we're saying
out of actors oh out of all of the kind
of like
hollywood vibed people yeah all the
creatives
sure okay so maybe not your
all the creatives i i'd say it's pretty
high
the i think how how high hmm [ __ ]
60 no yeah yeah that really that have
started it
didn't oh that have oh they've went up
to like level one or two up them
i think they've got gotten to ohm i
think most have gotten okay they've
gotten to own but they haven't made that
home
no i think they get to own ohm and then
they go that's pretty cool
i want to make movies and then they stop
caring i think okay that's interesting
got it so that's what you meant by 60
got it yeah and i was saying 10 actually
got to om and then we're like
this is [ __ ] insane i want to know
more about what om
actually is and then they get to that
true source as a home
and then go from there yeah the source
might be
thirty percent get to the source thirty
the concept
source if not higher because the
i think one of the big driving factors
that lead people to do art is that
they're just so discontent with
reality and so they're they're the ones
asking all the questions yeah yeah
they're the ones asking all the
questions and they're the weird kids in
high school
taking all the second decisions yeah so
they're all the people that want
answers outside of what's happening
around them because usually
growing up it's uh a pain a painful
experience
reality is painful right so i would
think that it's higher than
you know and then the next question
would be
how many of their managers and agents
are cool with them
coming coming on to a long form podcast
to talk about these things
because because how many people go look
at what gwyneth paltrow's reps let her
do you know she's she's all about this
kind of stuff
maybe not so deep and what about uh
duncan trussell and russell brand they
have a lot of
people coming on their programs yeah
that's true that are
that are they're talking about subjects
like that that's true well new age
new age thinking is pretty pretty in
vogue so
i think you could get a lot of them the
other thing is that you did say zero at
first which was interesting that want
them to
not that want them to but that no want
them to
because because didn't you say that
unless we have a direct
in to them which usually sometimes i
found that they have their emails
littered over the place in different
places and i'm able to send them a
direct message about it
um which usually that'll be intercepted
too but yeah exactly they've got you
know
um yeah you know the rep the rep might
uh uh
they'll then they might bring it up to
them they might not
you know a lot of times if something
doesn't seem worth it yeah because
they're like they're just gonna be like
yeah
why would i want my client
to go and talk about consciousness and
non-duality
what any benefit does this have and then
the selling point is
actually this example of them coming on
the program to do that
has the most benefit for their own
personal happiness
and flourishing as well as for
everything they touch downstream
i think that's the selling i think a rep
is going to be more like
um is this going to hurt their career
or is this going to help it and that's
and that's going to be and
the illusion is that it's going to hurt
because it has some sort of
negative detrimental effect on their
egoic
presence where whereas it actually
benefits
a lot it's actually quite fascinating
the
the backwards-ness which is part of the
perfect for perfection of it all one
thing
um one thing i've kind of noticed just
watching
is that a lot of a lot of people
and maybe it's the air of mystery or
something that you
you probably want to maintain as an
actor i think a lot of reps just even
with a long form podcast
might be a little more skeptical but one
person i would start out off with is
gwyneth paltrow that's what i want to
start with and if you could get into
touch with her
we will we will yeah because she's
already on this boat
yeah exactly she's already in a similar
exact
atmosphere and she's so he's not improv
yeah yeah that's true but um sorry i i i
mostly just look at actors but
yeah they're they're both two people
that are already
trying to bring these thoughts trying to
bring these ideas these new
approaches into the lime into the life
so is russell brand don't control
that russell brown's a huge one and
duncan trussell as well yeah yeah
so and i think i think you'll be able to
get some of those those are
yeah that's that's kind of the core
audience of
of um of it but also these kind of like
david dobrik's and stuff like that
logan paul's that kind of stuff because
if
if we can in a sense also get to which
they have already been expressing
interest in consciousness and these
types of things
slowly but when you get to them as well
what ends up happening is it's again
it's just that butterfly effect out that
happens
you know i was watching one of david
dobrik's videos and he literally said
in one of his videos he said that none
of this is real
and i was like oh [ __ ] he's already
there in his own way
yeah yeah so it's fascinating to one
time when i was in high school
and i was i was uh
doing a lot of stuff psychedelics and
stuff
i just like jump on a table i just start
screaming
can't you see can't you see it's all an
illusion
wow can't you see and i'm just screaming
it and then these people just started
applying
wow yeah and i'm in this big park back
when people used to go to parks and
they'd be full of people
i just jump on this picnic table can't
you see it's all an illusion
it's all made up man so i think a lot of
people
have hit that touch that i just don't
know if they've
yes grounded there exactly yeah wow
how old were you like 16. that's so
interesting
and you just got up onto in the park
yeah there was this park
with my friend yeah maggie god bless her
i love her
and you're just in the middle of the
peak of your trip no no no i wasn't even
tripping dude i was sober
oh but i i oh it was around the time
that you were doing oh i was just
super into this stuff man i was just
reading all the hundreds
i was reading all the books i was doing
all that you know
the electric kool-aid acid test i was
like we need to get a bus we need to do
this
yeah yeah yeah you've have you read that
the electric kool-aid acid test
yeah it's it's okay it's an all right
book the idea of what the married
pranksters was doing was cool but i was
so into that and i was just
learning yeah all the time yeah i just
jump up on this table
can't you see can't you see it's all an
illusion
i'm just like none of it's real
screaming it
and then these college kids are jogging
and they just yeah and i was like
and they're like damn they've done this
before they exactly
denver i mean they're about to legalize
mushrooms in colorado so
yeah and oregon already did and didn't
they
they decriminalized everything right
yeah and they
yeah and now it's smart yeah there's
yeah there's so much i think that's
smart everyone's like whoa
everyone's gonna do heroin like everyone
was already doing heroin yeah
yeah yeah now they just don't go to jail
netherlands i mean there's so many
examples of this flourishing
um tyler morrow holy [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] blast bro over what we
thought
wow bro good job yeah good job to you
sir dude
this was a good one that was that was
that was a lot more than i thought
it was it was a lot it was good it was
really it was really good
i really uh had a great time thank you
bro yeah likewise
we went into all the acting and
filmmaking stuff we went into all of
this
metaphysical stuff it was really solid
oh yeah
super soft oh yeah it was it was you
know i was kind of
i was expecting it you know light
lighter i'm glad you know we went to the
third degree we went the extra mile
yeah thank you thank you so much thank
you for having me
thank you guys thanks everyone for
tuning in yeah we
greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
that episode let us know how you feel
about what we
unpacked on the program about acting
filmmaking metaphysics all that stuff
also like the video if it brought you
value subscribe if you haven't share the
video with other people
that you feel would resonate check out
the links in the bio below to tyler's
imdb
also go follow him on instagram and
check out his
films yeah check out his films as well
the links are in the bio below
and
that's all indescribable perfection
and describe perfection man thank
i'm gonna put you shoes back on a piece
got a little sweaty next to the fire